la finale du concours de slam de danse
urbain une fois de plus tenu toutes ses
promesses
peut être le championnat n'a craqué et
chauffé à bloc par l'animateur survoltée
27 collèges participé à la 5e édition du
concours de slam et de danses urbaines
organisé par le conseil général
c'est notre cinquième édition du
concours de cela mais aussi de danse
urbaine avec des collégiens avec le
conseil général des jeunes nous on avait
initié cette action lors du 20e
anniversaire ça nous fait une cinquième
édition
aujourd'hui on voit on a 27 collèges et
on avait commencé avec sept ont été
assez plein les jeunes ont plein talent
il ya de l'innovation il ya de la
réflexion
il s'exprime il on est mieux ils ont un
outil où ils peuvent vraiment utilisé à
bon escient le t1 et aujourd'hui on voit
vraiment le succès est donc à vraiment
de l'enthousiasmé vraiment un grand
moment dans la vie du conseil général
des jeunes est d'un avis du conseil
général fois que le conseil général des
jeunes donc un premier pour la première
fois donc on place les concours de cinq
danses urbaines
pour ses 20 ans je conseil général des
jeunes et donc en fait tout s'est bien
passé
en fait pour nous jeunes vivre sans
musique sans mélodie sans sont bons
c'est difficile quoi et donc c'est la
raison pour laquelle on quand la donne
est donc un moyen d'expression les deux
tout le temps de rester dans la rue et
de s'exprimer comme ça
ben alors on donne donc on a mis en
place une manifestation pour que les
jeunes s'expriment et puis puissent
danser un domino reese dans la catégorie
slam
or
on est passé dit elle
le collège de l'étang saint paul qui
remporte le premier prix suivi du
collège marcel goulette il au collège de
la pointe des châteaux
pourquoi montrer du doigt la femme
l'homme étrangers il faut arrêter ces
injures plus de 100 sur le effet pendant
la q1
vous avez fait lundi dans la catégorie
danse urbaine c'est la démonstration de
qualité faite par le collège la châtoire
qui rafle la mise
donc l arrangement commun des gisements
bond inattendu avis bon les gars de
lausanne
en gamme des oublis
deux autres collèges se sont démarqués
sur la deuxième place du podium on
retrouve le collège saint-charles et sur
la troisième place le collège des
tamarins
un jury qui a eu beaucoup de mal à
délibérer devant la qualité des
prestations pour les collégiens et leurs
professeurs participent à ce concours
est avant tout un vrai plaisir chronique
par une vraie représentation sur une
vraie scène passer un message pour nous
ça un petit peu particulier parce que ça
nous fait venir de très très loin mais
c'est toujours un plaisir de participer
au concours du conseil général je te ça
permet en fait de mettre en forme
tout le travail qu'on a fait sur les
pauses méridiennes avec les élèves d'un
petit atelier de 6,7
et puis de découvrir aussi les jeunes
talents la reine
qui viennent un petit peu de partout
dans l'un des jeunes qui ont pu
s'exprimer grâce à ce concours alors si
vous aussi vous voulez tenter votre
chance l'année prochaine
rendez vous au théâtre de champ fleuri
pour déclamer eaux denses et peu importe
la manière pourvu qu'il y ait de l'art